foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
the truth is once you have your team in
there you said you're going to execute
there is nowhere to hide so yes it
brings about opportunities to bring
about your vision but all these people
are going to have to work very hard to
in order and make it happen I mean China
is not a place where something comes up
with the right idea and they try to put
it into legislation everything is
Thoroughly taken from the very top all
the way down to bottom then back up
again it's studied it's modeled they're
very very cautious about rolling
anything out until they know it's going
to work and then it's put into play so
this is not a situation where you know
these seven people are going to huddle
together and make plays out of you know
out of the back of their pocket and say
oh we'll go this way that way no it's
not the way it works in China and that's
part of the reason that they've been so
successful for 40 years it's a very
measured process
foreign
79 years old he had to be helped a
couple of times coming into the meeting
and people shouldn't read too much into
it
[Music]
patient yet
challenge
foreign
[Music]